not about six foot eight Levias long  walk her off the glass with his body on  eight and them rhythm I want the ball in  his hands 22 for Josh eight in the  corner  Kemba it's Walker time for the Hornets  loud Aten to not fly by but flying says  back this is about rebounding with five  guys attacking the glass and the  hesitation move side steps and connects  fourth quarter Kemba the crew that can  score that was a step back and stayed to  the right now it he made it look easy  that is a difficult shot right if you're  the Sun the new eagle you like okay  renovate this arena a bit all-star game  here they throw it into the backcourt  Kemba Walker avoiding Josh Jackson and  down go the son  [Applause]  Mount Druitt in from midcourt pretty  sure that did not count but it was a  fabulous finish who scored the last 11  Charlotte big discount it did did he get  it off I think it did